[Music]
i was a lot happier with what he had
done the first three games
than what's happened the last three
games but the big thing i would just say
it's not just him
jerry jones on his 77th birthday
after the loss that saw his team highly
talented team there's no question about
the talent level in dallas right which
means if you're not winning games
who's it on it may be on the head coach
and this is pft live monday edition nbc
sports radio nbcs and hello to our
friends in the uk and ireland enjoying
the program on sky sports but let's
start there we're going to talk about
teams we're worried about
the cowboys started off great they were
3-0 special season they lost three in a
row they shouldn't have lost the jets if
you lose to an oh a team that is
previously winless yeah that is not
special season right now they have to be
very concerned going into sunday night's
game at home against the philadelphia
eagles how worried are you about the
cowboy i i'm there's there's a little
bit of a worry factor i'm not gonna say
i'm like oh gosh they're in trouble and
then they can't turn this around i mean
like you said there is incredible talent
on this team uh here are some of the
things that concern me i mean yes it's
three straight losses the saints game on
the road hey i mean we know the saints
are good you know the second week okay
the the packers game i think what's
concerning there more than anything is
you know how they dug themselves into
the hole their defense made no big stops
in that football game early on and their
offense turned all over the ball and
then here we are
for the second week in a row as far as
that's concerned offense not finishing
drives having to kick field goals i just
was shocked by that they lost that and
of course now uh with the amar amari
cooper being hurt that's a little
concerning that adds the level of
concern up there but the defense you
know the way i just thought that they
would really make it really tough on the
jets yesterday clearly their defense is
more talented the jets offense and yeah
sam darnold was back and everything like
that but uh you know i just was shocked
that they didn't kind of overwhelm the
jets on that side of the ball a little
bit more i still think they can get out
of this funk but um they're gonna have
to tweak some things offensively and
defensively they can't just come out
every week and go this is what we do
we're more talented than you and our
talent will and our talent and hustle
and hitting will supersede all that no
hey new england's got talent that speaks
to coaching yeah so you're right you've
got to do some more game plan specific
things to give your guys some advantages
in certain scenarios that's what the
great teams in football are doing and
that's sometimes where on the cowboys
especially on the defensive side i'm not
seeing it right now all right let's play
the win-loss game 10 games left for the
dallas cowboys okay i'm gonna run and
buy you don't look it up i'm okay i'm
telling you i can see it don't look at
the screen i'm going to tell you eagles
this weekend win or loss quit looking at
the win win okay bye week no loss is
there at the giants back in that life
stadium i'm going to get i'm going to
give them the win all right vikings come
to town sunday night football week 10.
gonna be tough i'm going to give them
the win again all right that's three in
a row that's season three you sure about
that oh yeah add the lions
at the lions i might go lost there all
right at the patriots i'm gonna go lost
all right that's six and five at that
point buffalo bills your buffalo bishops
i know on thanksgiving right they'll win
an ugly one all right that gets them
seven and five you seven and five six
and four
seven five seven to five yep at the
bears i'll give them another ugly win
that's eight and five yes rams
man right now i'm gonna give them the
win i don't feel great about it i didn't
find i know and i don't know what's in
that coffee this morning
not what i want in there
uh i will give them the loss there and
then washington to finish the season and
then we'll give them the ones that's ten
and six seven and six right yeah
absolutely
it's close i mean yeah it's ten and six
it's nine and seven maybe it's eight and
eight it's somewhere in that range you
know i don't know the eagles the first
eagles this week that'll be big here's
the thing you had them losing at philly
yeah and they win this weekend
it's going to come down to those two
teams because the loser
of that division title whoever finishes
second in the nfc east is most likely
not getting into field because
those teams are both at three and three
either of those teams would be in last
place last place in the nfc north right
now right you've got contenders top to
bottom in the nfc north you've got two
teams at the top of the nfc west that
are great teams yes they are you got the
panthers and the saints in the nfc south
no joke there's gonna be three or four
teams that are good enough to get to the
super bowl who don't even get to the
playoffs in the nfc this year it is
crazy we've talked about it i think a
little last week the nfc is so deep and
so talented and so much better than the
afc
uh it's really not even close i mean we
can't even figure out who the number two
team is in the afc and the nfc we just
sit there and go wow it's one really
good team after another and the thing
you look at about oh i know who the
number two team in the afc is yeah who
you got going with the buffalo bills
yeah i hear you it's hard to argue that
at this point i mean the way they played
new england and all that i get it um so
yeah i'd probably make them the number
two team too but you're right there's
gonna be some really good football teams
in the nfc they're gonna be at home
watching playoff football and you'd go
man if they were over in the afc they
might be in the aic championship game
playing against the patriots also at
three and three the la rams who were
three and oh yeah you know it seemed
like the rams and the cowboys with the
class the nfc yeah the rams
desperate with extra time to face a
49ers team that was on a short week this
and you know we we we both believed that
this is a game the rams win because they
have to win and they're talented enough
to win it even without todd gurley
they're good enough to win this game and
the 49ers just went in there and shut
them down all this talk about offense
offense offense the 49ers defense is
great yes robert sullivan defensive
coordinator i think is a guy who's going
to be considered for head coaching jobs
coming up this year
because look at what he's doing with
that defense it helps when you've got a
murderer's row in your front four but
they have built that defense and it's a
great combination it's kyle shanahan's
offense and a defense set has been built
to mimic the way john lynch plays sure
you put those two together
you're right it's aggressive it's hard
hitting you know and kyle's that way too
i mean they don't want anybody that's
not willing to just basically run
through a wall and we see that their
defensive line just physically abuses
people and i think that's where i'm
concerned with the rams a little bit the
rams offensive line we've seen them be
overpowered this year a number of times
and i think that's where i go oh i'm not
so sure the rams can get out of this
funk maybe they can squeak their way
into the in the nfc playoffs as a wild
card team uh but i i'm a little more
concerned with them and then the fact
that their defense is still dangerous
but they're clearly not as dominant as
it's been in the last two years there's
some issues there they're letting them
more play they were good yesterday don't
get me wrong but you know we saw the
seahawks the week before move the ball
at will we saw the tampa bay buccaneers
put up 55 points against them so i am a
little concerned about the rams one
because of the big plays their defense
is letting up two i don't know if their
offensive line and run game are good
enough this year to
cover some of the other holes within the
rest of their team the weird thing about
the rams in contrast to the cowboys
cowboys won three games against bad
teams yes the rams beat the panthers in
carolina right they beat the saints
right through brees was injured in the
process they went to cleveland and beat
the browns
prime time so those are much more
quality wins right but then it all fell
apart 55 points surrendered to the
buccaneers then that loss to the
seahawks that would have been a win if
greg zernline makes a 44-yard field goal
and he's got to make that kick right and
then just smothered by the 49ers and i
almost wonder whether your desperation
mode that your rams are in like it
almost becomes a given oh we gotta win
hey we're the rams right we're the
defending nfc champions yeah we're gonna
win this game so maybe you're not as
desperate as you needed to be maybe they
weren't truly feeling desperate because
they just assumed this is that sunday
that they they flip it around well i do
think they have tremendous confidence in
themselves that they can you know they
can battle it out with anybody like you
said they've they beat some pretty good
teams to start the year uh now hey they
got the falcons this week the bengals
the week after so they're gonna be five
and three uh going into pittsburgh for a
week 10 match up but if they lose either
of those games are they done i i think
yeah i would i would say that would be
really concerning those are two teams
that they are clearly better than that
would tell me that something more is at
play here than just you know uh just
just like oh we've messed up in a gamer
here or there that there's something
fundamentally wrong like it is the super
bowl hangover and yeah just maybe the
attention to detail by the coaching
staff and the players isn't quite where
it needs to be this year but the big
thing that does concern me is their lack
of running game as compared to years
past that's where everything has focused
around and when they can't run this is
not a great offensive line as far as
pass protection is concerned and they
lose their starting guard yesterday and
they were already kind of weak on the
interior part of their offensive line
and i think that could be a real real
issue for them as we go forward you had
convinced me in the aftermath of the
loss to the buccaneers that jared goff
was spectacular in that game even though
he was being criticized and i think he
was spectacular against the seahawks
right yeah he was not spectacular sunday
78 passing yards yeah 78 not 178 278
078 for jared goff what in the world we
got to move on to the chiefs but what in
the world is up with jared well i i just
look at yesterday and you know i don't
care who you put back there you know i
just it looked to me every time i was
watching and we were trying to watch a
bunch of different games that he was
just under assault attack and i also say
this when they can't run the ball the
rams passing attack okay is not one
where i go i'm just like oh my gosh this
is the greatest thing i've ever seen
i've never seen plays and concepts like
this no mcveigh is more about running
the ball and then his packaging of plays
off running the football that makes them
special and him calling and the timing
of him calling plays when they have to
just become a throw the ball every time
i don't look at it like there's sean
payton or josh mcdaniels but they have
nine million different concepts that are
crazy i think that once it got to that
point the 49ers had a beat on some of
the things the rams like to do in the
passing game and we're all over it all
right uh the kansas city chiefs yeah
they were 4-0 they've lost two in a row
they have given up more than 180 yards
rushing in four straight games defense
is no better than it was a year ago
patrick mahomes when he's hobbled isn't
the same guy should we be worried about
them i'm worried but i will say this
there's at least a silver lining here
you know their offensive line is going
to get healthy okay that's been an issue
right now tyree kill
i mean tyra kill he just got back and he
looked good yesterday you know sammy
watkins needs to be out there this team
is built on their firepower and the
offensive side of the ball and when they
don't have that it hurts them because
you just talked about the defense is not
special and then okay their most special
player on defense a guy that's as good
as any d tackle the name not named aaron
donald and football chris jones he's not
out there so they miss him their defense
is not going to be anything special we
know that they have to outscore people
yesterday they got a bad break i'm not
as concerned about the chiefs i think
they can get this ship righted and uh i
think i just i still look at mahomes
andy reid and when when a sami watkins
gets back and i go
the chiefs are gonna be able to score
with anybody yeah uh they've got to do
it though yeah and it's amazing to think
that they've lost these two games at
home they're getting gashed on the
ground
and and when patron homes isn't 100 he
is not the guy that that we were gushing
about just a couple of weeks ago he's
got to get that ankle healed he's got
five more games until his bye week no no
definitely fight through it and the
short week this week at denver he could
lose three in a row i mean denver yes
yeah i mean denver will be able to move
the ball on the chiefs defense i mean
just about anybody can and we know
denver's defense is real the biggest
thing is they just got to figure out
whether they're going to put four
defensive tackles on the field or
whatever it is they got to stop
something or just blitz and get the
defense off the field like either you
make a sack or they score but mahomes
gets the ball but we've seen for three
weeks in a row teams controlled the ball
and mahomes is sitting on the sideline
drinking gatorade for the majority of
the game and that's an issue when you're
a high powered offense
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports